Donald Trump has now floated the idea of invalidating
and redoing the November presidential election
at some point in the future.
Trump did some kind of event commemorating
women's right to vote.
It was really bad from the get go.
And here is Donald Trump saying we might have
to redo the election because of all of the
voting that will be done by mail.
We have to have honest voting.
That's what this is all about here.
It's honest voting.
You can't take millions of ballots, send them
haphazardly all over the country or vote all
over a state and expect to come out properly.
And if you look at the last 10 elections where
they did this universal and by the way, absentee
is great.
It's been working for a long time, like in
Florida.
Absentee you request and it comes in and then
you send it back.
Absentee is great.
But universal is going to be a disaster.
The likes of which country has never seen
it will end up being a rigged election or
they will never come out with an outcome.
They'll have to do it again.
And nobody wants that.
And I don't want that.
So Trump's first salvo was that it might take
days to know the results.
Now, people weren't really worried about that.
It would be fine for it to take a few days
as long as we get the right result.
So Trump had to scale it up.
He had to go hyperbolic.
And then Trump went to saying, you know, it
could take days, weeks or even months to know
the results of the November election.
That just wasn't believable.
So more recently, Trump's been going full,
fake panic by saying it could take years to
know the results.
And now he's added this cherry on top, the
craziest, which is we might have to throw
out the election results altogether and redo
the entire election.
Now, what's funny is when he says that he
never says what would be different when we
redo it, like is the implication we would
have to redo the election.
But without any voting by mail or what what
how would the next how would redoing it fix
the problem unless we do the election in a
different way?
Doesn't really matter.
This is all crazy.
Now, Donald Trump also had announced on Monday
night.
This is so crazy on the way back from his
rally in Wisconsin.
Trump announced on Monday that yesterday he
would be making a big announcement about pardoning
someone.
And he said it's not going to be snowed in.
It's not going to be.
I don't remember whoever else.
And he made this announcement yesterday during
this same event commemorating women's right
to vote.
Donald Trump announced that he would be pardoning.
Susan B. Anthony, who died in 1986.
The announcement, which Trump had promoted
as a major announcement.
It was met with literal laughter in the room.
You have to see this video.
You have to listen to this.
You're going to hear loud laughter when Trump
says, I'm going to pardon Susan B. Anthony.
People think it's a joke.
And then they realize, oh, my God, Trump is
serious.
And they start to clap.
Sort of like politely out of pity.
I've never seen anything like this credible
document that I'm signing.
And I wanted to just add something, because
this was brought up a week ago and I was so
surprised that it was never done before, because
later today I will be signing a full and complete
pardon for Susan B. Anthony.
She was never pardoned.
Did you know that she was never pardoned?
What took so long?
The women behind Trump literally think it's
a joke that Trump is telling that it's not
real.
They thought this was going to resonate somehow.
The White House did.
Why else would they do this?
And then a moment that is indistinguishable
from parody.
Donald Trump is asked if he supports the protesters
in Belarus.
And Trump, I guess, heard protesters and terrorists.
And it just gets really weird.
It's like a weird Freudian slip combined with
Trump going off the rails and bashing the
protesters in Portland, Oregon, when asked
about Belarus.
Take a look at this.
Do I support protesters and terrorists?
Oh, yes.
Asian protesters and terrorists have a message
for Moscow.
Yeah, you have to send me.
I like seeing democracy.
Democracy is a very important word.
It doesn't seem like it's too much democracy
there in Belarus.
But we are speaking to lots of people.
And we'll be speaking at the appropriate time
to Russia.
And we'll be speaking to other people that
are involved.
But it's certainly a very big march and it
seems to be a very peaceful march other than
the other, unlike some of the so-called peaceful
protests that we have where they burned down
stores.
OK, peaceful protests, those are not peaceful.
Those are anarchists going over to Portland
and other places.
These are anarchists.
Agitators is a very bad people, just a complete
and total inability to discuss policy in anything
approaching substantive, a substantive way.
And then lastly, Trump is asked about Michelle
Obama's DNC speech from Monday, which even
Fox News said was pretty good.
And he says she was dead wrong.
We have way more corona virus deaths than
she said we have.
Trump's Trump's fact check, if you can imagine,
maybe because the speech was recorded a few
days earlier.
Trump's fact check is her speech was bad because
under my administration, we've actually had
way more corona virus deaths than Michelle
Obama claims.
You know, she was over her head and frankly,
she should have made the speech lives, which
she didn't do.
She taped it.
And it was not only taped to his taped a long
time ago because she had the wrong deaths.
She didn't even mention the vice presidential
candidate in the speech.
And, you know, she gets his fawning reviews.
If he gave a real review, it wouldn't be so
fawning, owning the Libs by saying, no, no,
no, Michelle was wrong.
More people have died of Corona virus.
Now, she recorded it a couple of days ago.
And then absolute last thing on this.
Trump again talks about how the Obama administration
got bad reviews on swine flu.
Notice if you're watching this video, the
woman over Trump's left shoulder.
She looks physically ill during this.
Take a look.
Well, they got very bad reviews.
If you look at the Gallup poll, Gallup poll
did a review of them.
Now, you have to understand that was a far
lesser vicious disease.
It was not the same in the same ballpark.
But let me I know it's also a much lesser
disease, but they got very bad reviews.
Gallup gave very bad reviews.
And by the way, Gallup at that same time gave
us very, very good reviews for the job we've
done.
So if you take a look at the Gallup poll from
a couple of months ago, we got very good reviews
and they got very bad reviews.
They were.
I mean, the reviews they got for the handling
of swine flu or H1N1, which Biden calls N1,
H1.
And I don't even correct them on that.
I don't even correct him.
I said, no, that's a mistake you can make.
But that's what he calls it.
He's got the he's got a little mixed up, but
that's all right.
Take a look at the Gallup poll.
And there are others, too.
They got horrible marks and that disease is
a much lesser problem.
And of course, we've already fact checked.
This during swine flu, the Obama Biden administration
had 66 percent approval in a polarized political
environment like the one that we have.
Sixty six percent approval.
Getting 66 percent of the country to agree
on anything is an accomplishment in and of
itself.
So Trump also wrong on the facts and making
people look physically ill from these rants.
And then Trump flew out to Arizona and it
got even worse.
And I'm going to talk about
that next.